this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
professional just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below
more about them in just a bit
few stars shine as bright as betty white
from the age of 17 she fought for her
place in a male dominated industry and
sustained a career that lasted as long
as her life the icon was beloved by
hollywood the stars that dominated the
box office and the audiences who'd
watched her for as long as they can
remember the pioneer of early television
lived an incredible life filled with
love laughter heartbreak success and
failure the only thing that ever changed
was betty white's unbelievably cheerful
nature an incredible sense of humor why
was a game changer in the entertainment
industry but it extends well beyond the
bounds of television she was not only an
actress and producer but she was also an
activist for animal rights racial
equality and lgbtq plus rights betty
white not only became a household name
several times over but she also became
america's grandmother a funny sometimes
unpredictable force of nature who
refused to go quietly into the night she
lived her life the way everyone should
try to live theirs with a drive and
tenacity delivered to the fullest
[Music]
on january the 17th 1922 a star was born
in oak park illinois her name betty
marion white but he was an only child
living with her mother christine tess
and her father horace logan white her
mother was a homemaker while her father
worked at an electrical company in oak
park and later alhambra before
ultimately moving to los angeles betty
white's childhood was not all that
different from a standard upbringing
during the early 20th century while
she'd late have a life filled with
excitement her childhood was incredibly
normal she attended school in beverly
hills and dreamed of becoming a forest
ranger this love of nature in animals
was instilled in her from a young age by
her parents they'd often vacation to
yellowstone ride horses camp and even
had some 26 dogs unfortunately during a
majority of the 20th century women
weren't allowed to serve as rangers her
next career path was to be a writer
eventually however why found her true
calling performance when betty white
graduated from high school she went on
an experimental television program with
her friend the two sang songs on what
was a new form of entertainment that
hadn't yet been fully realized she'd
tasted the idea of being a star though
and she wanted to chase the dream in
1941 the u.s entered world war ii and
betty white became a volunteer and spent
much of her volunteer time driving a px
truck with supplies but of course betty
never shied away from performing and
often did events for troops that were
out to be deployed it was a dark time in
history but it's also where betty met
her first husband dick barker a p-38
pilot in the u.s air force unfortunately
the marriage wouldn't last long as barca
dreamed of embracing a simpler life
post-war in ohio while betty was ready
to take on the world of show business
this would become a common thread for
whites who was a self-proclaimed
workaholic and nobody was going to stand
in the way of her reaching unprecedented
heights
as the war subsided betty white wanted
to take her dream and make it a reality
she started making her way around
hollywood and hoped to land herself in a
movie she starred in a couple of plays
and eventually just stuck around hoping
to get a job eventually oh i was told by
a producer that in order to get hired
you'd need to join the union but in
order to be in a union you needed to get
a job the producer gave betty her first
job which was a commercial that didn't
even pay enough to cover the entry fee
into the union but her father supportive
as he was gave her the remaining amount
to get her foot in the door television
was taking off on the east coast but it
hadn't yet reached the west coast and
why wasn't getting into films so she
started turning her attention to finding
a job on the airwaves soon she started
booking commercials bit parts and even
things like crowd noises after a few
jobs on popular radio shows at the time
like this is your fbi blondie and the
great gildersleeve betty was offered a
radio show of her own the betty white
show wouldn't be her big break but it
was the start of a blossoming career
during the 1940s white would marry again
this time talent agent lane allen the
marriage was another short-lived affair
only lasting two years allen wanted to
start a family which meant betty would
have to leave her dream of show business
behind why was dedicated to her career
and she couldn't sacrifice the gains she
was making in the industry the two
separated in 1949. in 1949 she soon
booked a role co-hosting hollywood on
television with al jarvis it was a live
tv variety show and by 1952 she took
over hosting the show solo when jarvis
departed and his replacement resigned
television back in the 1950s wasn't like
it is today hollywood on television was
a five and a half hour show that aired
six days a week while her co-host sat to
jump ship for other projects betty white
was always ready for a challenge and she
was rewarded for this challenge with an
emmy in 1951
white had always been a go-getter if
life wouldn't give her a break she'd
make it herself to come 1952 on the
heels of taking over as sole host of
hollywood on television white banded
together with writer george tibbles and
producer don fedison to co-found bandy
productions the trio would work on
taking characters from the variety show
and creating new shows and properties
out of them together they created life
with elizabeth it was a live variety
show at first which turned into a sitcom
becoming betty white's first foray into
a medium she'd dominate in later years
the series was live before going into
syndication from 1953 to 1955. the show
was a low-budget sitcom one of the
earliest examples of such a show it
became incredibly popular in its time
life with elizabeth not only was a
success with audiences but it won betty
white her first regional army in 1951. i
was doing something that wasn't all that
common back in the 1950s she was a woman
in television with a great deal of
control over the series she starred in
she was hands on both on and off camera
her tenacity and desire to do it all
were quickly establishing her as a force
to be reckoned with even if nobody had
truly noticed her yet
as is show business life with elizabeth
met its end with only two seasons and 65
episodes produced despite its popularity
producers felt that it wouldn't make
financial sense to continue at the same
time betty white was doing life with
elizabeth she was also leading the betty
white show it was like the radio show of
the same name but this time it was a
daytime talk show format once again
white continued to have immense creative
control over the project and she used it
wisely like hiring a female director
sometimes the creative control and
decision she made weren't to everyone's
liking and what was a politically
fraught time in united states history
the 1950s weren't friendly to everyone
in america the civil rights movement was
taking shape and coming to a head across
the nation betty white and the show
endured immense criticism for her
decision to include arthur duncan as a
regular cast member on the show duncan
was an immensely talented tap dancer but
he was also an african-american which
didn't fly for some viewers the
complaints got ugly when southern states
heavily practicing jim crow had
threatened to boycott if he continued to
appear on the show betty white famously
responded in a way fitting of the legend
herself she released a statement saying
i'm sorry but you know he stays live
with it to rub it in she gave duncan
even more screen time as the year
progressed ncb kept shuffling the show
around her different time slots and
slowly the audience dropped off come
1954 they cancelled the series many
theorized that her insistence on
bringing race into the show played a
part in its demise but there's no
definitive proof to support any
potential reason for the show's decline
in ratings following the cancellation of
the betty white show the young star
would go on to lead date with angels a
series betty white mentioned later on in
life was the only one she wanted to
escape however her time on the series
led to a meeting and becoming close
friends with lucille ball of i love lucy
fame this could have been considered a
slow few years for white but the best
was still yet to come
this is the age of creation if you think
about it for a moment you realize that
everyone on the internet it's not just
consuming stuff anymore we're not just
reading blogs we're not just watching
youtube channels we're making blogs
we're making youtube channels we're out
there making stuff or selling stuff
setting up a store and look whenever you
want to do any of that stuff yourself
well if it involves a website
squarespace is absolutely the place to
do it and maybe other hands-on type
you've got lots of opinions about what
exactly your website should look like if
so great squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical nonsense to worry about or
maybe you just need something functional
something that's gonna work very quickly
well in that case just use one of their
beautiful templates boom boom you go in
you customize it easy and it's done and
once you're done setting up that website
locking in the name maybe playing around
with the design whatever squarespace
provides tons of extra stuff so your
site can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
options 24 7 customer support everything
you need in one place so when you're
ready to get started on the next project
of yours big or small it involves a
website do it with squarespace go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and now today's video
starting in 1958 betty white began a
long string of appearances on talk shows
and game shows this began with just men
the tonight show with jack part to tell
the truth and on the password series
starting with the original password she
was a staple guest in almost all three
of these shows but the most meaningful
and memorable was her many appearances
on password it was on password in 1961
that betty white met her third and final
husband password host alan ludden this
wasn't like previous marriages betty
white had had this one would last a
lifetime blooden already had three
children from a previous marriage and
the two were both career-driven
individuals it was a match they didn't
show business heaven their connection
was instant and visible to anyone who
watched them on password they continued
spending time together for several
months even working on a play together
and meeting his kids ludden would
jokingly ask her to marry him but one
day it became much more than a joke why
would say no for a year and a half
before finally saying yes and marrying
him in 1963. betty white would later
admit that she regrets not saying yes
sooner because it meant she wasted a
year before she could have been with
london following their marriage white
continued to appear on the subsequent
password shows like password plus super
password and million dollar password
because of her relationship with the
host and her countless appearances why
was eventually dubbed the first lady of
game shows the 1960s had shaped up to be
a great decade for the actress she'd
married the love of her life featured on
many game shows panel shows and stage
shows and even made her film debut in
the 1962 film advise and consent she was
also an anchor on nbc's breakfast show
today while initially interested the
thought of moving to new york caused her
decline the job which eventually went to
a young wide-eyed barbara walters the
late 50s and most of the 60s were some
of white's collective 19 years as a
hostess commentator and contestant on
game shows then came the 70s and 80s
where white would experience a career
leap that would take her from the first
lady of game shows to the upper echelons
of sitcoms
the early days of television gave birth
to some of the most iconic sitcoms in
history sitcoms like i love lucy
bewitched maud and the mary tyler moore
show were considered to be some of the
best of the best in 1973 betty white
began appearing on the mary tyler moore
show and she became so popular playing
sue ann nivens that eventually her guest
role turned into a full-time gig come
season five onwards betty white's very
existence on the mary tyler moore show
resulted from mary tyler moore's
intervention they wrote the character of
suanne nivens as someone who was as
sweet as betty white while also being
vicious they began their search but
eventually mary tyler moore who was
friends with white suggested they just
hire her instead there was a slight
reluctance at first by the producers
because of the existing friendship
between the two stars but eventually it
was undeniable that she was made for the
role like garnered major success thanks
to a run on the show she won two emmys
back to back for her work in 1975 and
1976. the mary tyler moore show wrapped
its seventh and final season in 1977
leaving white without an ongoing job for
a while betty appeared on a short-lived
reincarnation of the betty white show
various sitcoms talk shows panel shows
game shows and even some movies and
mini-series in 1983 she achieved another
career first and that was winning the
daytime emmy award show for outstanding
game show host for just men the
mid-1980s would bring betty white her
most important role to date the role
that truly gave her the recognition
she'd long deserved first she'd have to
injure heartbreak that she'd never felt
before
while eddie wyatt was about to walk into
one of her most successful ventures the
80s brought heartbreak at 63 alan ludden
passed away after battling stomach
cancer and a stroke white never
remarried and she stated in a 2011
interview that i had the love of my life
if you had the best who needs the rest
after the initial grieving period betty
did the only thing she knew how to do in
moments of pain work in 1985 betty
joined the cast of the golden girls she
starred alongside b arthur who garnered
success playing maude in the series of
the same name rue mcclanahan who also
starred in maude and worked with white
in mama's family and a fairly new
actress in estelle getty the series
followed the lives of four elderly women
in miami florida betty white played the
naive and slightly daft rose nyland a
saint olaf minnesota native the golden
girls enjoyed one of the most successful
runs in television history it lasted 180
episodes over seven seasons winning the
cast many awards and nominations for
golden globes emmys and more betty white
herself received one emmy over the
course of the series run but was
nominated each season as well as
receiving four golden globe nominations
betty white almost played the seductive
blanche and rue mcclanahan almost played
rose this would have essentially
typecast them as they both had played
these kinds of roles in their previous
sitcoms the mary tyler moore show and
moored respectively the director of the
pilot jay sandrich suggested they switch
roles he only directed one episode of
the series overall but his change would
set the foundation for a highly
successful run the show while about
friendship between its main ensemble
members wasn't all perfect behind the
scenes betty white and her co-star b
arthur famously didn't get along as well
as their characters did on screen white
would often explain that arthur just
wasn't a fan of betty's upbeat attitude
and that it made them butt heads in 1992
when the show ended it wasn't because of
a decline in ratings or quality it was a
decision made by arthur to bow out of
the role she felt that it was time to
move on 1992 saw the finale of the
long-running series where 27.2 million
viewers watched and said goodbye to the
golden girls there was an attempt to
keep it going as a spin-off called the
golden palace it followed three of the
four main characters as they attempted
to run a hotel the show didn't see it to
season two but white made a few more
appearances as rose and ireland an empty
nest and nurses before retiring the
character for good
coming off a highly successful series
like the golden girls doesn't mean it's
over once the show ended and the
subsequent spin-off was dead betty white
did what she does best guest starred in
a bunch of series she continued
garnering emmy nominations and wins for
some of those guest spots like yes dear
my name is earl and the john laraquette
show well i would also have some
recurring characters in shows like the
bold and the beautiful and boston legal
why made a return to the latest version
of million dollar password in 2008 as
well as many appearances on the tonight
show with jay leno and the late late
show with craig ferguson it was during
this time that betty white's fame
plateaued it had been well over a decade
since golden girls ended and despite the
guest spots on many television shows she
wasn't the household name that she once
was however a few upcoming roles would
start a betty white revolution and
resurgence in popularity that would last
until her death in 2021
[Music]
2009 was a major year for betty white it
saw an unlikely resurgence in her career
that lasted over a decade it started
with a role in the romantic comedy the
proposal in the film white played ryan
reynolds grandmother the film wasn't a
major hit with critics but the everyday
moviegoer couldn't get enough of it
another major moment was betty's
involvement in the incredibly popular
snickers ad which was featured at the
super bowl the combination of a role in
the proposal and the snickers ad led to
a grassroots effort to get betty white
on snl as the host of an upcoming season
episode the campaign which was hosted on
facebook gathered 500 000 members
eventually what was confirmed as host
for the upcoming season and she became
the oldest person ever to host at 88
years old it included betty white
fashion the appearance on the sketch
show landed her another emmy win why
continued this success by appearing on
tv lands hot in cleveland initially only
slated for a guest appearance in the
pilot white's character of el kostrovsky
became her latest leading lady role
which she continued for the series six
season run again she garnered a
nomination for an emmy for the role but
she didn't win this time around during
the 2010s white was keeping herself busy
for all moon in her 90s she starred in a
few movies and hosted a prank show
called betty white soft their rockers
for which he received another three emmy
nominations white even won a grammy in
2012 for the audiobook of a bestseller
if you ask me in 2015 white did another
episode of snl which would ultimately be
her last she continued appearing in many
shows movies and documentaries at such a
late stage in her career betty white was
firing on all cylinders and that didn't
stop until the very end
betty white's always been a firecracker
she was never afraid to fight for what
she believed in say things that were
sometimes unexpected and make millions
laugh almost effortlessly throughout her
life she was a major animal rights
activist she wrote books starred in
shows and created calendars and clothing
lines to raise money and awareness for
animal rights it was the one thing she
loved more than anything but he was also
a friend to the lgbtq plus community
who'd grown to love white and her
co-stars of the golden girls throughout
its run and by its performance in the
mary tyler moore show she was loved by
almost anyone you asked and for
different reasons but the foundation
always was her kindness and compassion
in december 2021 on new year's eve betty
white passed away at 99 years old months
away from celebrating her 100th birthday
throughout her career betty white broke
barriers and records from her star on
the hollywood walk of fame next to her
husband alan luddens to her countless
accolades and accomplishments betty was
a game changer white remains the only
woman to have garnered emmys in every
comedic performance category white also
holds a record for the longest span
between emmy nominations and
performances her first nomination
happened all the way back in 1951 and
her final was in 2014. i was an actress
producer philanthropist activist
honorary mayor of los angeles an
honorary forest ranger fulfilling a
lifelong dream and one of the world's
most popular and trusted celebrities
when betty white died on december 31
2021 her last word was alan whom she
longed to reunite with one day for over
70 years betty white lit up the world
with a career some actors can only dream
of having